hallo mein name ist bond viele meinen
dass ich sehr schlecht oder gar io bin
und was hilft gegen einen schlechten
spieler
was haben wir denn hier wir haben hier
agrio expeed zoomen visitor doppel ja
das ist ja schon mal ganz gut an diese
you in on ag ios zooms pieter dozentin
visibility klimas connector addio wir
dann 50 mails vor hektik activator acht
das ist ein download scheiße das
wirklich nicht agaven joecks world
klingt okay was hat denn da was macht
der denn da der das ist total unsinnig
weil er sich einfach an die nächsten
dinge heran zieht das macht vollkommen
keinen sinn die bewertung sagen es auch
schon aus 1365 leicht gegen 7 2 6 okay
okay ist wenn die working for the game
that means der can be virtual control
movement tür bei der players interviewt
ist ein händler ich bin da genau der
gleichen meinung wie in animus we would
you me der hex hex hex hex vor hexa
fokussiert kemmer schauen ob wir damit
etwas reißen können
warum kommt comcom computex akkus welt
wie wichtig das bleibt doch lass dich
fressen von mir gut ich bin einfach so
schlecht in diesem spiel tritt vegleich
team kommen komm bitte holt die jugend
ein hexer von bossis du musst dich
einfach mal durchsetzt mit einer message
kommen wir müssen ihnen doch sein okay
da ist jetzt glaube ich gleich groß als
ob hier einfach keine anderen spieler
sind wieso kann ich dann einfach kein
fresse ist hier denn niemand der
irgendwie in einer annehmbaren da mehr
da kommt die ich jetzt oder dänemark
oder wie auch immer denn
denn tags in focus ich sehe mein gott
ist er rechts riese ich hab mir squeeze
ja kommt huizing frist wie sie gleich
groß denn ein chip chip chip chat oder
per post an die ich krieg oder irgendwen
oder donna war dadurch etwa verbindet
euch verbindet euch schnell schnell
schnell schnell verbindet euch verbindet
euch verbindet euch schnell schneller
schneller
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein
nein nein eine hockey challenge cups
geschafft jetzt geschafft ins geschäft
kommt compper verbindet euch freude
vermittelt euch damit macht euch
zusammen hexa focus kommen wir schaffen
das das macht euch wie macht man das
sie könnte sich wieder verbinden was
soll das macht doch mal irgendwas ja
kommen bei ihr und jetzt hier beiden
noch ya ya konan kommt zu bilden wir
sind wieder weg im race alter wir haben
es echt geschafft vor diesem einen
spaten dahinter abzuhauen
aber wir müssen da durch das wir jetzt
uns hier keinen hack drin haben sondern
aufgrund unserer hex hex hex research
herausgefunden haben dass ex für putzig
sind müssen wir jetzt in andere noch
zeigen dass ex-präsident und das bist
trotzdem irgendwie schaffe
mein gott ist pure großer bedenken kommt
van oder und ein extra police hat ich
gegessen so schnell geht es nämlich
nicht auf gott da ist wieder die
niederlande
das kann auch nicht sagen wieso sind die
mir dann immer auf den fersen wieso
warum ist das ein kleiner kreis rum ihr
sollte ich einfach kommen bei ihnen ja
ja ja kommen werdet 1 wertet 1 werdet 1
nein da ist schon wieder die niederlande
das ist doch nicht wahr
die systeme gerade denn da david o nein
nein nein als ob wir noch ist kann noch
nicht sagen da bin ich aber dass die
niederlande geht doch weg verbindet euch
kommen schnell stellen die niederlande
kommen jetzt ja ja ja und jetzt ist er
unten da unten rechts ist die
niederlande da müssen wir doch irgendwie
hin kommt ich kann die niederlande nicht
alleine wieder und dann die sind nicht
würdig jetzt nein ihr verbindet euch
nicht niederlande
nein niederlanden
nein ist nein das ist doch nicht das
kann doch nicht sein wieso habe ich das
nicht geschafft
hahaha das ich muss doch dich du jetzt
mal irgendwie ich brauche doch mal
irgend wenig fressen kann der
ansatzweise so groß ist wie ich komm ich
brauche jetzt einfach mal so ein kleines
erfolgserlebnis haben das irgendwie
irgendwer sieht dass ich auf jeden fall
auch ort steht jetzt sind sie auch noch
genauso groß da kommt großer gelber
kreis kommen jahr redet redet kommt
comcom und da habe ich den gefressen und
jetzt doch eben redet in der ecke klären
kommen das kann doch nicht so schwer
sein jetzt jetzt jetzt komm komm komm da
ist der mond aber nein nein nein der
mond kriegt mich auch nicht der monat
sie gekriegt das jetzt nicht wahr
verbindet euch die bastarde macht
irgendwie dass die einst werdet kommt
das ist doch nicht so allzu schwer ihr
müsst doch irgendwie jetzt jetzt kann
mich nicht mal mehr aushalten mit hektar
vier pussy kann er auch vielleicht vom
mond weil er ganz großes aber sonst
niemand da sie der reddot reddit com
komm komm komm komm ich kann mir doch
jetzt wie immer reddot schnappen oder
irgendwen kommen fressen fressen
ach ich habe immer so riesige pläne wie
ich irgendwann verfügt noch mal kriegen
kann und dann schaffe ich einfach nie
mein leben ist am arsch die danke polen
danke jetzt grad viel zu viel los hier
ist viel zu viel zu viele leute gerade
hier auf dem weg unfassbar viele leute
das wird mir gerade echt ein bisschen zu
zu riesig verschmelzt euch ja nein jetzt
ja da holy holy 2 mio das wird mein
erfolg dich kriege ich dich kriege ich
dem smiley dich kriege ich du kommst
letztlich so einfach davon wie jeder
andere fressen fressen höre ja ja ja ja
ja nein wieso sind wir gleich gross ja
was habe ich getan hat nicht getan was
habe ich getan mach dich wieder auf
vollbild jetzt hier
hol dir den smiley wohl ihnen die
komplexe pussys ich kann mich so gar
nichts nützen weil wir dann locker
wieder gleich groß sind aber komm hol
ihn dir bitte bitte nein da kommt die
niederlande das ist doch nicht wahr das
ist doch nicht jetzt macht mir die
niederlande da wieder ein strich durch
die rechnung die blöden [ __ ] jahr ist
dass viele bedenkt sich macht ihm hat
nein niemals habe ich mit ihr die hh
wieso seid ihr alle so groß ich nein
nein nein nein nein
du kriegst mich nicht da kriegst mich
auch nicht keiner von euch
[Musik]